that's amazing he's a happy baby nearly
one year ago Rhianna and ASAP Rocky
welcomed their first child a baby boy
and now the world's learning the little
guy's name
according to the Daily Mill which
obtained a copy of the official birth
certificate the couple named him Rizza
Thurston Mayors it's all an exciting
Journey so far I'm just taking it as it
comes Riri and ASAP seemingly took inspo
from the iconic music producer and
Wu-Tang Clan member Rizza which is cool
you know and get this Rihanna's been
repping Rizza and Wu-Tang since the
baby's arrival looks like that little
guy of yours is pretty energetic and so
happy what Mom does is are you I'm in
love I'm obsessed and I don't even feel
guilty about it what is the best part
about motherhood right now Rihanna oh my
God the morning's just like seeing his
morning face yeah and you know like
seeing a baby with like little bags and
waking up and they're just like startled
they're trying to figure out where they
at is the cutest it's my favorite part
of the day oh my God the mornings that's
like I I cherish that yeah Reed's
definitely loving motherhood and she's
about to enjoy it times two the singer
announced she's expecting her second
child during her epic Super Bowl
halftime show earlier this year
[Applause]
please don't call me
being a new mom nothing would have
gotten me out the house if it wasn't a
challenge like that you would accept not
been messing around or maybe you have
for how pregnancies treating her this
time around I think different from the
first one
um just everything all of my
no Cravings tons of nausea everything's
different but I'm enjoying it I'm
enjoying it I feel good I feel energetic
it's unclear when exactly Rihanna and
ASAP will welcome baby number two but
here's hoping we don't have to wait too
long to find out the little one's name
[Music]